Film Courage: Scott, what made you want to be a writer? Scott Myers, DePaul University Professor/Screenwriter/Creator Gointothestory.blcklst(dot)com:
Gosh I grew up an Air Force brat. My
father was a colonel in the Air Force so
we moved around like every two three
years and that meant there was a lot of
time left for just being by yourself
because you know you have to takes a
while to make friends and whatnot and
living in unusual places like Alabama
and Minot North Dakota Lintott itself to
a lot of time for reading and I just
started writing I was writing short
stories very early on when I was a
college I took some creative writing
classes but I kind of let that slide I
was more interested in songwriting I did
that for many many years and so that was
my main focus did you kind of write your
own story for when you had to go to a
new school like almost your own bio sort
of like hi I'm Scott I'm the new kid in
class well the interesting thing and
this is actually paid off as a writer is
that I discovered early on the quickest
and best way to make friends is to ask
questions and just listen to them and
they think you're the best friend in the
world
because you're there to hear them and
they get into a habit of knowing that
you will wear the conscious or not they
know that you will listen to them and so
the relationships that's problematic
because on the one hand I'm not really
revealing much of myself but I am
learning a lot about other people and so
I kind of got I tell people I got a
non-official BA in Psychology just by
being an Air Force brat and moving
around and paying attention to all these
people and figuring out the dynamics of
groups as I would come in and find out
where I could fit in and as you know as
a writer you spend so much time with
your characters and doing the same sort
of work where you're asking questions to
them and about them and thinking about
their interrelationships so in terms of
my own biography it was pretty simple
when I was an Air Force brat and we
lived on Air Force bases and so people
sort of knew what that meant how did
your family embrace the idea that you
wanted to write I realized that wasn't
your original plan though I think they
were always encouraging me
to their regret they bought me a guitar
when I was 14 because I went off to
college and graduate school and I was
going to become an academic but I was
playing music and my last year at Yale
my graduate program the three year
masters that I was gonna do before I
went in and got a doctorate I just felt
like I felt like I shouldn't be there I
really did feel like I was not aligned
with what I should be doing and I had
this horrible image of myself down the
road as a successful teacher you know
professor at a university and my study
beautiful books desk
the single bankers lamp late at night in
my guitar case in the corner collecting
dust that was literally an image I had
and so I knew that if I didn't pursue
that creative Avenue that I'd be
disappointed and so I took a year off
and that became the rest of my life so
as soon as I started writing songs when
I was fourteen I knew that there was
something about writing and creativity
that was an essential part of who I was
and I had to pursue that in some respect
do you still write spec screenplays
today yeah it's interesting I mean I did
break in in 1987
writing a spec script called k9 it's
sold to Universal and then became a
movie starring James Belushi was
released in 1989 and then there were two
sequels off that I had a 15 year period
where I lived in Los Angeles and wrote
30 plot projects for every major studio
on every broadcast network except for
ABC which is why a joke is why I don't
watch ABC now you know but nowadays I
teach at the DePaul University School of
Cinematic Arts in Chicago full-time I've
evolved into that and so I don't write
as much in terms of screenplays right
now I do have one project I'm working on
with the producer because I'm an
academic now I mean I've finally fully
entered into this academic world so I'm
writing a book I'm writing a book on
screenwriting and that's my major area
of focus but I do have a novel that I
want to write and I have another
screenplay that I have waiting you know
and when I have a chance to write it
yeah do you think there's an energy to
where you write like when you were in
Los Angeles for 15 or so years and then
going to Illinois and then I don't know
if you thought are written in Virginia
or wherever is there a difference where
are you right like what she produce when
I was here I had a little formula that I
would use it was 1 to 5 or 5 to 7 which
meant that I wrote from 1 to 5 in the
afternoon and when I was pounding out a
first draft it would be 5 to 7 pages so
if I hit 5 pages by say 3:30 I'd say ok
I'm done because I found that that's
basically as much as I could do apart
from saying like going away for a
weekend it's just jamming out 60 pages
which I've done too and it didn't really
matter where I would write it just had
to be quiet I'm not one of those people
that can go to coffee shops I'd like to
have even while I'll put white noise on
sometimes to avoid you know outside
interruptions but now I do most of my
creative writing late at night like
Monica
in the morning because that's when
everything stops you know in terms of
emails and whatnot but I do think it's
critically important that for a writer
to have a space and a time preferably a
daily routine I just think that you know
I've interviewed a probably 200 writers
on my blog go into the story and that's
one consistent thing you hear is writing
every day so while I'm not writing spec
scripts actively right now I still do
write and I am writing this book so I
write you know I write the book during
the day and then I'll rewrite it at
night do you think your discipline comes
from having been around there you know
you you you were around sort of this
very regimented sort of environment
that's that's a big part of it you know
growing up a military and military
family there was a very strong routine
and my father had high expectations for
us and that has both good sides and
negative sides to it also I grew up with
a very strong Protestant work ethic you
know I like to work I really do and but
then the third thing is the creative
it's the passion I mean I love story I
love movies
one thing being a military brat when you
move around as much as I did
one of the constants was movie theaters
the weather could change from Alabama to
California to Ohio to North Dakota the
the general sort of topography and what
you could do outside and when you could
do it depending upon the weather that
could vary but every Air Force Base had
a movie theater and it was subsidized by
the federal government so like when I
was a child I was literally going to see
movies for 50 Cent's 75 cents and I
would go in the summer
like every day and watch movies and so I
developed an enormous passion for movies
I I love movies I don't think there's
any greater form of entertainment and
storytelling
these and so yeah there is a certain
amount of routine and there's a certain
amount of just liking to get work done
and setting goals and meeting those
goals but the most important thing is
that passion just to really lean into
that and embrace it so that's why it's
so important to pick projects that
you're passionate about
has anyone ever challenged you on that
and said you know what Scott you can
take a week off and tried to say like
don't work so hard but you feel like
that's gonna throw you off your rhythm
no I I have a you know right because of
my blog I've been doing enough for
almost 11 years I tend to interface with
pan teaching I tend to interface with
people and come up with these little
sayings you know and one of them is
there's no one right way to write every
writer is different every story is
different and so anybody who says this
is the way to write you know I would
push back on that and so for example one
of the questions I'll sometimes ask
writers when they interview them is
what's your best excuse not to write
right it's very funny to hear them you
know well ESPN or the the great baking
show or whatever I think is in you know
from England or whatnot but I remember
interviewing a writer who said to me I
don't need an excuse if I want to take a
day off I take a day off because I know
I'm gonna get the project done on time
and so there have been times like when I
do that yeah I can take some time off
you know but again
I'm confident I'm gonna get it done
because I've done so many you know
scripts in them and gotten the you know
from faded to fade out
do you believe you will sell another one
of your screenplays that's not even
really you know much of a consideration
for me now I'm you know I'm I'm of an
age where well first of all the industry
has changed so much it's really hard to
sell material nowadays particularly
original material in fact there are some
who refer to original content now as
being untested that's how addicted
Hollywood is to pre-existing content you
know to IP intellectual property so
prequels and sequels and remakes and
reboots and sequels which is a sequel
with women you know females doing the
roles of like ocean's 8 and ghostbusters
right so the numbers I've track on my
blog I've tracked ever since 1989 really
got broken at 87 but since 1890 1989
I've tracked spec script daily deals
because I was you know wanting to see
what the market was doing and there was
a big rise in them in the 90s that was
kind of the Golden Age of the spec
script and then it's fluctuated you know
but now the last few years it's been
pretty depressed in terms of the market
so and and I teach now that's my
full-time job you know I write as I'd
say it's a bit more than a hobby it's
not you know it's kind of an avocation
you know I mean like spec scripts and
stuff so that doesn't concern me
you know what concerns me is is my
teaching and I have to say I never
expected it I always just did it as a
there's a side thing but now that I'm
doing it full-time I really feel like
this is my purpose right now is to be a
teacher I just have here's a story for
you so I was just at the Willamette
Writers Conference in Portland Oregon
and I got there my first night Thursday
night and I'm having dinner and some
people came up to me because they
recognized the long haired dude who's
got the blog right well I like your blog
and so far this young guy comes up and I
look at his eye he looks familiar to me
and he said hi my name is Sam you may
not remember me but
you you I took two of your classes at
the University of North Carolina and
that's when I was living in Chapel Hill
and I taught adjunct and he said that
really changed my life because I had
never anticipated that I would get so
connected to that stuff and he has since
graduation than a literary agent he
never would have thought of that he's
now with the agency that represents
Stephen King and george RR martin oh wow
and so and he said I talked to my
clients about story and they go wow you
really know this stuff he said that's
all professor
UNC so that's the kind of thing when you
hear that sort of thing it just is
incredibly reaffirming and inspirational
I mean to be able to influence people
and to encourage them to follow their
bliss you know pursue that they're
passionate about and they do it and then
you know some have some exciting success
like that that's just your right thing
well even yours your vlog is going to
story dot blacklist go into the story
yeah it's going to the story dot be lck
LST about Tommy on the blacklist it's
the official screenwriting blog on the
blacklist yeah very nice well it's it's
a teaching blog in that do you have all
these wonderful questions you say like
commonly asked yeah I mean there must be
like a hundred questions there oh okay
there's hmm 26,000 articles on the blog
I know it's insane I blogged every day
for nearly 40 100 straight days I mean
that's just my the subtext of that is
that I'm gonna I'm gonna track the
business no matter what so why not and
I'm gonna reflect about writing you know
every day no matter what so why not just
take like 45 minutes to an hour and do
my blogging and the subtext is if I can
do that every day you can write every
day you know I don't make it a big deal
but I'm hoping that people will go oh
okay yeah I can write an hour a day you
know if you write one page a day this
was something that Larry Gordon who
produced k9 told me he said if you write
a page a day you can write to spec
scripts in a year if you spend a month
prepping the story for months page at
820 pages
and a month rewriting that's six months
that's a spec script and you do that
twice twice a year you get two spec
scripts excuse me
it was just do you do you anticipate
writing another spec script in the meter
but I know you're writing a book yeah
and and very busy so yeah the book is is
something that I'm excited to do I've
had many many people approached me about
doing that before and I didn't really
feel it was appropriate at the time
given what I was doing but this was a
Palgrave Macmillan which is a very well
known academic press out of London and
what they're excited about what I'm
excited about is the particular angle on
the material which is character driven
screenwriting so it's called the
protagonists journey a character driven
screenwriting and storytelling and
what's really unique about it is that it
takes the work of Carl Jung who's found
at analytical psychology and who was
hugely influenced on Janet Joseph
Campbell and I discovered Joseph
Campbell when I was in college and
brings his ideas to screenwriting
I think of all the screenwriting gurus
and all the how-to books that Carl Jung
is the greatest screenwriting guru there
is his theory of individuation is the
protagonist journey and we can apply
those ideas to get writers to focus on
their characters really drill down and
lean into their protagonists you know
what is their state of disunity why are
they disconnected from their authentic
nature because that is an in fact what
the protagonist does in 90% of movies
they go from a state of inauthentic life
what I call disunity to more of a state
of authors on authenticity and that's
what the individuation process is in a
nutshell and so I'm very excited about
bringing that content into a book form
and sorry did Carl Jung come up with the
archetypes he the word archetypes has
been around but yes he was very very
much about that and he believes in the
collective unconscious so there are
archetypes that exist out there that we
dip
- it's why say for example stories that
lean into these narrative archetypes are
even character archetypes that there's
like a second level of connection
there's the story itself in the
entertainment but there's this
unconscious thing that be going on we're
there tapping into that those archetypes
and so for example I have discovered
that in in watching movie after movie
after movie and reading screenplays and
studying this that there are basically
five primary character archetypes that
we see over and over again there's the
protagonist that forward-moving energy
has a goal there's an oppositional
dynamic you know most people call it an
antagonist I call it a nemesis so you've
got the protagonist versus a nemesis
along the way the protagonist meets
people who are ostensibly allies
sometimes they're not but there's a
character type that deals with the
protagonist emotional development and I
call that character an attractor
character sometimes a romance character
but not always then there's a character
type that influences the protagonist in
terms of their intellectual development
and that's the mentor which we've all
heard about right and then there's a
fifth archetype which has a very very
long standing tradition and indigenous
cultures throughout the world and that's
the trickster the trickster is a
shapeshifter
it's an ally enemy enemy ally and so
they test the will of the protagonist
essentially creating challenges and
obstacles and problems that they have to
overcome like pop quizzes leading to the
final struggle at the end and so we see
these five archetypes that exist in I
could walk you through dozens of movies
right now if I had the time where we
just see that and I thought well that's
fascinating and actually Young has not
something like that but he's got a
construct that is similar to this
character map that I've put together
that will be in the book so you know I'm
just curious I do you teach my curiosity
with this let's say it's Forrest Gump
Wood Wood lieutenant Danny be the
trickster sort of this chameleon who's
testing us well the interesting about
Forrest composit Forrest is is one of
those is one of those stories were the
it doesn't change he's a change agent he
changes other people and so I guess you
could say that yeah Lieutenant Dan is a
trickster in the sense that at first
he's very anti force it is not one he
did not want to be saved he wanted to
die because he had the legacy of his
whole family tradition of men and
military who died in the field of battle
and so he's he's pissed off at force and
he's angry and he tries to you know
Chris he's wheelchair-bound because he's
lost his legs you know and we see him
drinking and whoring and just basically
doing everything he can to to forget
about his life but Forrest keeps coming
back and his earnestness and his
affection for Lieutenant Dan so that by
the time he they joined together into
the shrimp boat thing right there's a
moment where dilute ended dance out in
the water swimming and Forrest says he
thinks that he finally came to peace and
of course it's a beautiful ending where
he does attend Forrest wedding with
Jenny and he's got those titanium legs
and he's married a woman from Southeast
Asia so he has an arc okay Jenny has an
arc right he's I would say that she's an
attractor character obviously that's the
character that he's the most emotionally
connected to you know so but a more you
know an easier example to talk about
this in terms of like a character goes
through a change would be so take a
movie like The Wizard of Oz the
protagonist is clearly Dorothy and we
think of that lovely song she sings
somewhere over the rainbow right but she
talks about trumble's and clouds right
she wants to go someplace else she
doesn't feel like her home really is a
home she's an orphan
she's the only young person there she's
dressed in these crisp little dress
every like at work clothes she doesn't
even have a job she gets in the way of
the people in terms of their jobs and so
it takes her to have to take this trip
to Oz classic heroes journey
construction right where she has to go
leave the ordinary we'll go to the
extraordinary world and through those
experiences there learn when she comes
back that there's no place like home
but the character she intersects with
our
in that experience so for example the
nemesis character miss Gulch and she
says you wicked a which well she becomes
the Wicked Witch of the West rights and
providing opposition she wants those
ruby red slippers and she's you know a
threat to Dorothy but then there's a
mentor character and that's Glinda the
Good Witch
you know those shoes go see that you
follow the Olympic Road that's providing
insight that's what mentor querque she
wakes them up when they fallen asleep
her but the poppies she wakes him up
with the snowfall so she's an and she
provides the biggest piece of insight at
the very end of the movie sit where she
says Dorothy you've had the power all
along
you just had to realize it and so that's
a mentor figure the trickster character
is clearly professor Marvel The Wizard
of Oz you know who shape shifts there's
actually that actor Frank Morgan plays
five different roles in the movie which
is like a perfect example of a trickster
shape-shifting and then the attractor
character scarecrow tinman and Cowardly
Lion who become her best friends and
because they are related to hunk Hickory
and Zeke back in on the earth that at
beckon you know Kansas that is a bridge
for her to feel a connection now to
Kansas so when she comes back home she's
got auntie em and Uncle Henry and those
three so we see those five you know
those five archetypes but I could go
through Casablanca and Silence of the
Lambs and just movie after movie this is
the case how does someone who wants to
become a professional screenwriter
approach it like a professional
screenwriter what is their mindset what
is their time like what are they doing
that's different from someone who just
says I want to be a writer and both have
equal talent but ones approach and
mindset is different from the other one
that yeah yeah I want to be a writer but
doesn't do that one that's a really good
question I had one of my students from
our line is now a very very successful
TV show runner and soon to be directing
a movie that she wrote
and I had her that's ELISA joy she who's
co-executive producer Westworld and she
came to a class that I taught it in
Westwood for a weekend seminar and that
question they post that question to her
and she said well I was working as a
lawyer and and before that was going to
law school and the way I approached it
was I'm going to act like I am a
professional screenwriter I'm gonna
approach this like a job and so
obviously you know how do you do that in
terms of hours but set that aside that's
the mentality to have and you have to
really immerse yourself in it and it's
not just about writing the script it's
about learning the craft and so one of
those things that I came up with years
ago from my blog which is watch movies
read script write pages those three
things are absolutely essential you've
got to watch movies sometimes you're
just kind of kick back and enjoy it but
then there are other times you stop it
scene by scene and you write a scene by
seeing breakdown and you're looking for
where the plot line points land the
major events that twist the pot in a new
direction you're looking at subplots and
those little many stories and my anti
stories and how they play into the to
the a story you're looking at characters
in terms of their transformation of art
so there's watching movies and sometimes
you do it in a very rigorous fashion
then reading scripts Simoni you can just
sit there and just kind of blow through
a script and enjoy it but then you can
also do a same thing you can do a scene
by scene breakdown you're doing the same
sort of analysis that you would if
you're watching a movie reading scripts
is absolutely critical particularly
scripts written in the last five years
because the style changes constantly and
so people who tell you well you can't do
this you can't do that much more
important for you to read scripts of
professional writers movie scripts where
you are seeing how professionals
approach the writing and you're then
taking that knowledge and bringing it to
bear on your own writing and then of
course writing pages and you know I have
this thing I came up with my blog that
seems to be quite popular which is one
two seven fourteen one is read one
script per week two is watch two movies
per week seven is write one page a day
seven pages and 14 is 14 hours a week
you should be basically two hours a day
you are researching another project
you're rewriting a project you're doing
character development you're doing story
development you're generating and
assessing story ideas you're tracking
trends you're reading the trades you
know if you want to do this if you
really want to do this you have to
understand that you were competing
against people who are very serious
minded and have a lot of talent it's not
easy in fact the odds against success
are just enormous
but the way to do it is to approach it
like you're a professional and so if you
can carve out 20 hours a week let's say
16 hours a week you know 2 hours a day
you know as opposed to going in eating
lunch you know with the buddies for an
hour and a half well use that time to
actually do some work as a writer you
know you need to learn the craft and
then exhibit what you've learned on the
page so that when you've written that
script it speaks to someone you know
someone will get it and see that this is
a professional writer
what does character development entail
are you writing a backstory to me that's
everything it's everything here's
another one my sayings ready begin with
character and with character find the
story in between I don't care what
paradigm people have in terms of story
structure how you get there is critical
and so you start with your characters
that's my take you know it forget
there's not one right way to do this I'm
just saying that this I think is a
there's a smart way to go about it
because the characters it's their story
if we're writing a story we are assuming
that in some magical mystical way that
story universe exists those characters
exist and if it's their story they know
it better than we do and so character
development is about getting curious
it's about asking questions it's about
spending time with the characters and so
the typical things that we see like
biographies and questionnaires
those are great I call those in direct
engagement exercises because you're
reflecting on the character you're
thinking about the character as opposed
to direct engagement exercises so for
example what if I have a character in
mind I'm going to imagine I am a
psychiatrist this character is my
patient and if they're reticent to talk
to me I can even go and step further
they have been court-appointed to appear
with me as a psychiatrist and they have
to answer my questions that they don't
they will stay stuck in the situation
until they do so you just create a
situation in which like I was saying
earlier you just ask questions you get
curious when I was but that's a lesson I
learned when I was an Air Force brat you
just ask people questions I'm talking
and so you just you type you just let it
go you can even do something it's a
little bit spiritual I suppose you'd say
in a way where you're gonna do either a
monologue or a stream of consciousness
with a character it's sort of like a
Vulcan mind meld you know like Star Trek
where you get a character in your mind
and you do some deep breathing you get
yourself so you're transitioning out of
the busy world and you're gonna be here
now
with this character and you set a timer
for like 15
that's you put your fingers on the
keyboard or pin on paper and you close
your eyes and you just type and you just
type and you know your mind will go oh I
got to get groceries or the cat whatever
just look like though you don't get
attached to it you just keep coming back
to this character and you get done with
this and so you've got all these words
that you've typed out some of them are
like dialogue like a monologue and some
of them are just like stream of
consciousness 80% of it may seem like
gobbledygook to you maybe 90% but 20% or
10%
there's something really interesting
that popped out there and that's getting
in touch with the characters in at a
subconscious level and they start to
talk to you I've seen this happen time
and time again I created a a prep class
10 years ago that I teach online
six-week workshop taking a story from
concept to outline and the first four
weeks are all character development the
second week is brain storming that's all
they do is brainstorm
and I've had hundreds of people tell me
that was the most eye-opening experience
for them was doing that type of work
again the characters exist we act on
that belief and we reach out to them and
get them talking to us so the character
development that's those some great
examples are character development can
happen out of that is if you identify a
protagonist in particular their state of
disunity where they are disconnected
from their authentic nature and that can
inform if you know what the disunity
state is that can inform where the Unity
State is and so now they're not gonna
just jump there then you're gonna say
okay so these plot elements and a
characters with whom they intersect
they're gonna deconstruct their old ways
of being because they don't work out
here in the new world but in the process
of that they're gonna uncover their need
their needs going to start to emerge
this is very Union young talks about he
says when an inner situation is not made
conscious and he's talking about like
conflict inner conflict it happens
outside as fate
now I don't know if that's real and you
know in the real world but that's the
protagonist story the protagonist starts
off in a state of disunity and what
happens in the plot is informed by that
there's a synergy between it it's not
just these random events it's like these
characters that they intersect with and
the events that they go through that's
going to provide the basis of their
transformation and so their disunity
that gets deconstructed well now this
stuff starts to come out into the light
of consciousness their need and then
they move into reconstruction now
they're moving into their new mode of
being and eventually toward unity so you
can take that raw material that you get
with your with your characters and see
how that starts to shape the nature of
the plot the story structure and it's
not just plugging this in you know this
has to happen on page 25 the the
break-in to act to know you're doing it
through a much more organic fashion with
your characters and letting them inform
you what the structure will be and the
final value of that is that you're
writing multi-layered richly textured
characters who actors want to play so
character development to me is like
everything it's it's absolutely critical
I'm loving this disunity to unity sort
of transformation can we use this as an
example for a film sure well there's so
many you know that's why I call the book
the protagonist journey because it's you
know Hollywood loves happy endings and
even indie films generally have a happy
ending and so that's that positive arc
you know there are movies where
characters don't go through an arc they
don't they refuse to change or they go
through a negative arc like Charles
Foster Kane and Citizen Kane started off
in a state of unity in Colorado and he
was yanked out of there and he always
just wanted to go back then it's with
the snow globe represented right but so
he ended up in this dissolute state and
eventual despair and death but most
movies have a positive arc and so for
example that this unity to unity those
four movements that's my language system
there's other ways to refer to it and by
the way this aligns with what has become
more and more
popular now amongst pro writers I know
to thinking of the structure of four
acts as opposed to three if you look at
the psychological journey of the
character you know that these four
movements echo that so let's look at a
movie like The Silence of the Lambs
so Clarice Starling is in a major state
of disunity at the beginning she her
father was killed when she was 11 years
old so she was orphaned she was sent to
her uncle's Montana farm where she had a
horrific experience where basically that
all those negative associations of death
and whatnot were attached to an
experience she saw when she witnessed
the spring the slaughter of the spring
lambs and that's why she has these
dreams that's an example of the
unconscious trying to come into the
light of consciousness her dreams right
and so she's she's become a law
enforcement officer her father was a was
a you know Sheriff's Department but she
doesn't become a sheriff no she goes to
the behavioral science you and FBI which
deals with like serial killers and the
motivations and the mindsets of people
who are and assess evil she is drawn to
that because she wants to understand how
these guys could have killed her father
so she's got all this going on she's
also a woman in a heavily male
environment and she's trying to hide her
West Virginia roots as Lecter here says
you know no more than three generations
and pull away trash right well that's
good so so she's in a state of disunity
and when I've said that young quote you
know if the situation is it remains
unresolved
it happens outside his fate it's when
Jack Crawford invites her in to go
basically to tease and tantalize Lecter
to try and get clues about the Buffalo
Bill case that had to happen she had she
could have met any other serial killer
it had to be Hannibal Lecter why because
he's a psychotherapist
and he could lead her into herself she's
never going to be able to move to unity
unless she deals with that stuff that's
deep deep down in her subconscious so
he's the perfect pert
he's the mentor in Silence of the Lambs
even if he's a psycho
he's not the nemesis the nemesis is
Buffalo Bill right so she has to go on
this journey and she's pulled out of
being an agent in training so now she's
in the field with Jack Crawford
she's Jack Crawford tells her
point-blank when the first meeting
don't let Lecter inside your head which
is exactly what she does she lets Lecter
inside her head because she knows
intuitively that that's where she needs
to be she needs to have this guy of
course she's doing it ostensibly because
she's trying to get clues to save
Katherine Martin who was a kidnap victim
Katherine Martin in my view is the
Attractor character because Clarice
identifies with her you know Lecter says
he believed he's a Paul Katherine Martin
you can stop the awful crying in the
land
she's a young single woman just like
Clarice she's from the South just like
Carla Reese she's a victim just like
Clarice was in terms of her parent
getting killed so you've got this
journey of her becoming more and more
less and less afraid of being like a
rookie and more and more embracing her
role as an FBI agent remember she does
that autopsy where she finds that clue
with the with the moth seed and the one
of the victims mouths so by the midpoint
she's really starting to become more
proactive so he's deconstructed her
always being also deconstructed her fear
about telling the truth to elect her
they make that deal quid pro quo you
tell me things and I'll tell you but
nothing I don't hear about the case from
you I want to hear about your personal
life and so she does start to talk about
her personal life leading to that big
moment where she confesses the Montana
farm to Lecter which is key because she
has to face that fear and so she's
reconstituted she's you know
reconstructed now and much more
proactive in fact once
lectors gone he escaped she says it's
all over but then she realizes Lecter
gave them a clue again mentor figure we
covet what we see and so she now
realizes ah the first victim was someone
that Buffalo Bills saw so I'm gonna go
to his hometown and she does is on her
own
she's completely proactive now she's
bending rules she is doing what she
needs to do you know embracing her power
and all of that is to set into motion
the final struggle between she and
Buffalo Bill buffalo bill represents the
boogeyman the guys who killed her father
so she's got to face them and if you
look at that less that last act and is
so great and in the silence that Lance
because she keeps going through doorways
one threshold after another she's got to
go through deeper and deeper into
Buffalo Bills and lair and so she faces
down her nemesis and and she kills him
you know so that's a classic example of
a character who goes from disunity
toward a state of unity through those
four stages and so Lecter would not be
the shapeshifter chameleon Chekov
there's actually the trickster
characters Jack Crawford who because he
lies to her he's using her as bait to
get Hannibal Lecter he if there's a
scene in the autopsy where she's
surrounded by all these men these male
and he's he gets the head of the the
sheriff's guy let's go talk private you
know and he does this thing like he's
saying let's get away from her so he's
in it he's an ally but he's also kind of
an enemy and she calls him on that and
then even at the end where she says
she's found out that the Buffalo Bill is
a seamstress and you know she's at the
home and and in in Crawford says no no
we've got that we know areas he's in
Joliet Illinois we're gonna go we're
gonna go get him thanks for all your
help so she's not you see what I'm
saying enemy ally ally me also Alex
Chilton who's the the head of the
psychiatric were the prison where Lecter
is he's also a trickster
remember he hits on her like in the
first scene he says you know Baltimore
could be kind of a fun town if you know
and then he also plants a recording
device in there he's listening to her
talking to Lecter and then takes Lecter
away from her to Memphis so those are
your trickster characters I think lect
and Lecter cement or the attractor is
Katherine Martin and and the nemesis is
Buffalo Bill
what makes a good story a good story
well you can't stray too far from
Aristotle beginning middle and end you
know but you've got to have some
emotional tie-in you've got to have some
characters that you care about and you
got to have a situation that's
compelling that they find themselves in
so those are three key elements a
structure but a central character
typically the protagonist character that
we experience that story if I carry
ously through them and they go through a
series of challenges in a compelling
situation and most often we like to see
them really put to the test really
challenged and we like to see them
change you know Campbell talks about the
whole point of the hero's journey Joseph
Campbell is transformation and I think a
big reason why that's the case why
stories and movies in particular you
know in a two-hour period you have a
character starting off one in one state
of their psyche you know state of psyche
their state of being and they end up in
quite another we want to believe we can
change you know that's the message that
Madison Avenue with every commercial by
this product you'll be better you know
we want to believe we can change and
stories give us a hope that we can
because they're about characters that do
change but again you got to have a story
structure but the main thing is you got
to have a character we relate to or
emotionally invested in they go through
a series of challenges and tests and we
see them change over time if that's a
compelling enough set of circumstances
in which we find them then that's the
basis of a good story can we think of a
film that's done quite well where if the
character hadn't been so interesting or
their transformation wasn't so stark
that if you hadn't plugged in that
character the story would be no good it
was so simple or it didn't really work
because the characters journey was so
profound it resonated with people I
think it's like almost any story I mean
if the
the protagonist isn't compelling if we
don't have a an emotional connection to
them then what's the point right
like I'm a huge Pixar fan I've got sons
who are nine and a half years apart and
came along at the time where I was
basically forced to see every Pixar
movie I say forced I just meant because
they came out and the kids wanted to see
them which was just a wonderful blessing
for me because Pixar is just you know
phenomenal storytellers and I know
because I I know Mary Coleman who's the
head of the story department there and
Pixar that nothing gets greenlit there
unless they know quite clearly what
those points of universal connection are
to the audience how is the audience
going to tie into the story emotionally
so I would say that any great movie or
any great story that traffic's of that I
mean there's got to be something going
on even if it's an antihero movie where
there's something human there that we
can connect with that we can relate to
taxi driver for example a Travis Bickle
there's a guy he's lonely you know he he
wants to go on the date he is living you
know he's just loneliness right there I
mean everybody at some point has been
lonely or felt like an outsider or an
outcast and so that's it that's enough
right there that I'm interested in the
guy to see how he's existing in one of
the most heavily populated places in the
United States you know Manhattan in New
York so I would say that that's
absolutely critical you've got to find
that point of emotional connection I'd
say it even goes further than the Met
you as a writer have to find how you're
emotionally connected to the character
because that's the kind of passion that
can manifest itself on the page where
the words
lift up off the page and into the
imagination of the reader because you so
are so dialed into that character that
their experience infuses your own
writing so it's absolutely critical that
people go to movies to think yes and be
entertained yes but I think
fundamentally they go to movies to be to
feel something well if we take slightly
older movies once that had a Humphrey
Bogart
so Maltese Falcon or Casablanca whatever
I'm wondering how do we feel that
connection even if we don't see
ourselves as his character whose
characters always had a lot of
confidence maybe they were a little more
jaded or cynical they were always kind
of the truth tellers but how are we
happy into those same Humphrey Bogart
character okay so let's take Casablanca
which is the number one script on the
WGA top 100 scripts or 101 which is
ironic because they never finished the
script never really had a complete
script on set but what's his issue his
did he's in a state of disunity at the
beginning he started off as a loyalist
he was a passionate believer in you know
the good and the right he fought in the
sight of the loyalists in the Spanish
you know the war he falls in love with
Ilsa they had that wonderful adil ik
experience in Paris then the Germans are
coming into town he goes to the train
station she doesn't show up his hearts
broken so he goes to Casablanca and
starts this business he drinks alone he
plays chess alone he does have
presumably some sort of sexual dalliance
with that one woman but there's no real
connection there and he's a complete
cenek at this point he's cut himself off
from that idealistic part of himself
that used to exist and so that whole
hard-boiled humphrey bogart you know I
came for the waters and when I was
misinformed that whole thing right
that's just that's a mask that's his
cynical mask that's his public persona
inside is his idealism is his passion
for life it's still there but it's
buried it's in the
like pretty young it's in the darkness
of the unconscious it needs to come out
which is why it happens outside is fate
who shows up and where Ilsa of all and
he says of all the lousy Jen joints in
the world you hadn't right yeah it's
like the biggest coincidence in the
world or is it it's like fate fate shows
that you know determines that she show
up there because he's got to deal with
his past so she's clearly the attracter
character for the protagonist right and
so how do we relate to that how many of
us have been jilted how many of us have
had our hearts broke in a relationship
you know that's pretty Universal I'd I
suspect that 90% of people have been in
a situation where they had their hearts
broken we can relate to that with this
guy it's that's when you really boil it
down on a human level that's what this
guy's dealing with for all that bluster
and all that business savvy and
everything else and that cynicism he's a
guy who had his heart broken so there's
AB universal point of connection so then
these set of characters show up there's
major Strasser who represents the
Germans he's the Nemesis character right
because Rick's got these letters of
transit and originally he's thinking
about taking he and Ilsa once they
reconnect he's gonna take her and off
they go getting out of Casablanca
but there's the mentor figure Victor
Laszlo
who knows that rick has that idealistic
side there's a great conversation that
they have when Laszlo comes in on from a
meeting and he said his wrists injured
and so Rick and he sort of stand of the
bar and Laszlo tells him as much
basically intimates that he knows that
this guy can come back and be on the
side of the good side on the right and
so and you've got Captain Renault who is
one of the great tricksters of all time
I'm shocked shocked to find those
government even going on here you know
he plays all sides right for his own
good um so at the end Rick does get in
touch with his idealism and he does
reconnect with that part of himself
because he e he moves from selfish to
selfless he gives the letters of transit
and Laszlo and Ilsa go off
and he's contributing to the to the to
the side of the good so but the main
point circling back to your point we
relate to him because he's had his heart
broken and that's a universal thing so
even though it's it's Sam Spade in
effect you know they're in Casablanca
he's still a guy who's been crushed
romantically and emotionally
where does the creation of a great story
begin I think it varies from story to
story from writer to writer you know
I've interviewed so many of them some of
them start with a theme I don't do that
you know theme of central theme of
themes or a central theme of a story
will emerge over time but some people
start off with a thematic point of view
a lot of people start that I have
interviewed and this is more where I'm
at start off with a character or
characters and I think that works
because if the character is interesting
and you can mind that then that's where
people can find those points of
connection some start off with a story
concept I I do this thing on my blog
I've done it now ten straight years you
got ten years called the story idea each
day for a month so in April every April
30 days I collect stories along the way
in my computer and then I just run one
each day and I say okay so here's the
basis of this news article what would we
do with this is there a movie and get
people to think about this I'd say what
if we did this is a drama wait a minute
what if we did this as a thriller what
if you despond it this way like I just
heard one on the way over this is
amazing so a guy is a Dallas Love Field
today a passenger you know waiting to
take off when there's this hubbub there
and as it turns out they're bringing
back to the body the remains of a guy
who fought for the United States in
Vietnam and they've recently discovered
his remains his son was five when he
last saw his father at that base leaving
to go to Vietnam the pilot of the plane
flying his father's remains to Dallas is
his son is that amazing so they they had
all of the people like all those people
who do the luggage and they created
these line
and they had a water they were doing a
water tribute they're shooting about
fire hoses and stuff they had military
guys there and the guy who said it was
that everybody was pressed up against
the windows because this word had spread
that this was happening and he said it
was the irias thing
nobody's phone nobody talking nope of
the luggage everybody just standing
still watching this reverent moment
happened
so I'd say things like the news articles
you know I don't know if that's a great
story or not but it's it's a it's a
wonderful moment but maybe that's an
opportunity to be you know a story so I
think it can happen from anywhere you
know be open to it
the magic words what if right mark
Norman's son calls him up and says what
if Shakespeare had writer's block and
that was the inspiration for Shakespeare
and love that hook written by James V
Hart came about like breakfast
conversation where his son said what if
Peter Pan grew up so I think concepts
are big I think they're really important
now maybe as important as they were the
kind of high concept thing that we
talked about in the 80s and 90s so much
because of this whole idea that unless
you've got some sort of pre-existing IP
you know Hollywood scared to green-light
that so it takes a really really strong
concept a strong story concept so I take
theme characters story concept I mean
those are all you know I love the Coen
brothers the way that Miller's Crossing
started was this image of a hat being
tossed across a creek in the woods
that was literally where that started so
whatever it is you know find if you're
passionate about it and if you're
passionate about it then write the hell
out of it you know I'm sorry why have
the screenplays changed in terms of
reading one let's say from 20 years ago
from 1/2 years ago in terms of are they
are things written in a briefer manner
yes
now this is where one area I feel pretty
confident that I understand pretty well
I used to teach a class called the
history of American screen
which was created by my colleague down
at the University of North Carolina Dana
Cohen and I taught that class I think
four times and it was really a brilliant
class because it would go decade by
decade starting with like in the 1890s
every week was like a different decade
1900s and 1910s 1920s and so you're
studying the evolution of screen writing
and filmmaking particularly in the
United States and the role of the
screenwriter in the process particularly
in Hollywood one of the things that we
did in that class was we looked at
screenplay structure and format and
style as it evolved over time in fact
the term screenplay didn't really come
into existence until the 30s and 40s
before then it was known well it's
basically just a shot list and then it
became known as a continuity during the
silent film era but then what's talkies
came along then they started bringing in
Hollywood started to bring all these
playwrights did the dialogue right and
so then it became a screen play two
words so if you look at movies from the
30s and even into the 40s you'll
oftentimes see that credit being screen
play as a screen version of a play so
then eventually screenplays kind of
became a little bit more of their own
thing and we joined them together a
screenplay
so I've studied this quite you know
comprehensively and I know for a fact
that it's always evolving so that's
always cracked me up when people say
well you can't do this or you have to do
that it's always evolving it's
constantly evolving so for example if
you look at if you look at scripts from
there were no things as selling scripts
or spec scripts back in the 40s and 50s
and 60s it was all for hire all 40s and
50s thirties forties and fifties and so
is all these things were filled with
shots you know close-up zoom and all
that stuff what happened what's the spec
scripts market evolved was director said
we don't want it we don't want you to
tell us how to direct the movie
we're directors we're going to do that
so then we pulled out that journal a
speaking we pulled out that camera
jargon a directing lingo and so that led
to the whole we see we move we hear and
then that started to get a bit tiresome
and so then what we started to do is
just just describe what's happening and
so then when I first broken was like
okay so every paragraph you should try
to have no more than five lines as
opposed to like these big blocks of 15
20 30 lines because it's much easier to
read script readers are in effect the
threshold guardians of Hollywood and we
try to make it as easy for them to read
as possible nowadays I think that you
know the general feeling and this is not
a rule but the general feeling is that
the paragraph should be no longer than
three lines but a better way to think
about it does not like that sort of
regimented thing I think the better way
to think about it is each line of scene
description each paragraph of scene
description that's a way of indicating a
camera shot
you're not saying it's a camera shot but
if you think about the scene as you're
writing it and you're thinking okay
that's a close-up I see that is a
close-up and I see this as a as a wide
shot I see this is a medium shot now
you're not saying that in the script but
you're breaking up each paragraph to
suggest that that's a camera shot that's
a great way to not only direct the
action on the page but also ensure that
your paragraphs aren't that long you're
breaking them up into one two or three
lines so scripts today this is why it's
important yeah it's great to read the
older scripts but it's really important
to read the scripts that come out
nowadays because the styles are
constantly changing we're seeing
something happening right now and I
don't know if it's going to continue to
go this way but including images and
scripts like if you read the script that
Brian woods and Scott Beck did for a
quiet place it has an image of their
Monopoly board it's got an image
comparing like the Statue of Liberty and
I think the Eiffel Tower and then this
big tower that's out in the field
they're just so you get a sense of it
they change font sizes they use one page
is like a word on it or even a letter
you know um so it's much more
really graphic and I guess it makes
sense because movies are primarily a
visual medium some people may resist
that as being kind of a cheat but we're
starting to see some of that now and I
don't think that's necessarily wrong it
could be that we eventually that's what
screenplays become they do include
images and you could certainly make an
argument that why not
because again it's a it's a visual
medium so it's constantly in a state of
change which is why if anybody tells you
you can't do this or you have to do that
then then you know you're not talking to
the right people
you need to read scripts by professional
screenwriters and see what they do and
realize that we have a lot of latitude
to tell the story the best way it needs
to be told
and maybe that's why emojis and
different things have seeped into I
don't know if you've received papers
that it happens like an emoji in there
or here or there but it's become part of
communication images you see them in
scripts because of texting now you know
we wouldn't we didn't have texting you
know until 15 years ago or whatnot right
so when you don't you know some people
of mine University students will try to
do that as dialogue is it well it's not
really dialogue it's its own thing and
so that the typical thing now is to to
do left margin' just like you're doing
action right and you do you know the
name of the character : and then their
little texting thing and it can have an
emoji in it and then you do a shift
enter you don't do two lines the last
space you do shift enter so it's right
under there the next text shift enter
the next text and that's how most people
that I know handle texting but yeah
emojis would be there we wouldn't you
know we wouldn't who knows in ten years
we'll be doing something different and
that's gonna be reflected and the
screenplays you know kind of matrix
thing yeah
is outlining a must again every writer
is different I would say that if you
have any pretensions of working in TV
yes no script goes that no project goes
to script no episode unless they break
it and prep and that typically involves
either a beat sheet or an outline on the
feature side of things if you're writing
on spec you know if you've got 12 months
and you want to just start with fade in
and see where it goes that's okay but I
definitely recommend outlining if you've
not outlined you should outline at least
once and see what that process is like
the way I approach it that I think
enlivens the experience is as I said
before we work with the characters so
week one but agonist character treatment
asks seven key questions of the
protagonist so you're engaging them and
really digging down into who they are
you know questions like what do they
fear the most
that's an interesting question you know
why does this story have to happen to
this character at this time think about
their sort of place in life second week
we do brainstorming is like some of
those exercises I was talking about
questionnaires biographies these direct
engagement exercises interviews and
monologues and streams of consciousness
third week we now move to the plot so we
talk about what's the beginning of the
story what's the end of Act one what's
the end of Act two and what's the end of
the story just get a sense of those four
primary plotline points but we're also
identifying subplots my principle there
is subplot equals a relationship so
whatever characters you've come up with
the primary characters in your story
then start to look at them in terms of
their relationships and if you can work
with character archetypes that's very
helpful oh this is a protagonist
attractive relationship this is a
protagonist mentor relationship being
Center and so you start to think in
terms of subplots and week four we do we
move to the psychological domain and we
talk about these four theme line
movements disunity deconstruction
reconstruction unity so for the first
four weeks it really is focused on
character and by the time you get to the
last stage where we're busting out 3x5
inch index cards and do
that whole thing you know that you've
spent so much time with the characters
and generated so much content that it's
there's a vibrancy to it there's an
aliveness there's a vitality to it it's
not just literally plugging in this to
that and this to that and this to that
you're really seeing the story unfold
and you're sensing to how the characters
are involved in the protagonists
psychological journey and their art so I
would say it's not mandatory to do an
outline I highly recommend it you know
if you feel that it's better for you to
write a treatment version of it the more
literary thing that's fine too or a beat
sheet but like I do outlines and they
can run to 25 30 pages long like single
spaced because I put everything in there
like what's the simple conflict where
these characters lines of dialogue
effort how I'm going to get in and out
of the scene transitions to the next
scene I put it all there so I would say
I would extremely encourage people to do
an outline yes and particularly if they
want to work in TV they just absolutely
have to so let's say somebody doesn't
want to do an outline and you say all
right that's fine that's your style I
even though I hope it and then you read
their script and then you see that
it could have benefited from them taking
time seeing a story from what's your
answer to that well here's what here's
the thing I'd say nine times out of ten
I'm not going to get that script because
they're gonna crash and burn by page 50
or 60 because they don't know where
they're going
anybody can write a first act it's three
you know you get an established of key
characters the story universe central
conflict the the atmosphere and tone
something happens you know the inciting
incident or the call to adventure and
then something propels them off into
this new world right well so you can
probably off that energy go okay the
next 10 15 pages and then okay maybe
five more on but I don't know where I'm
going
maybe I better figure this out okay so
alright another 10 15 but well that's
stupid that doesn't really work oh wow
and so you know people will get I think
the number one reason why people do not
finish a script is because they don't
know where they're going
if you do an outline you do know where
you're going like well you're familiar
happen DC there's a Chesapeake Bay
bridge-tunnel I do a blog post on this
is pretty funny the Chesapeake Bay
bridge-tunnel extends from Virginia
Beach up to the Delmarva Peninsula which
is Delaware Maryland and Virginia right
and it's long it's like 20-some odd
miles long and so you've got this span
which is a bridge and then there's a
tunnel for like a mile and a half which
is creepy enough because you're like
under the Atlantic Ocean in this tunnel
then you come up and there's a mid part
of the bridge and then there's another
tunnel and there's another part of the
bridge that middle part of the bridge
which is about ten miles out if you go
during the day you cannot see land
anywhere there's no land you're on a
bridge in the middle of the ocean if you
have an outline at least you know where
you're going and you just keep going and
going because that middle of the story
the act too can be so discombobulating
sometimes and so you you know where
you're going because you've got the
thing broken so you're trusting that
you're gonna come out the other end so
but yeah I have rats absolutely I've
read scripts where I go gotcha they just
didn't they didn't nail the structure of
the structures a mass or but if there's
something there and the characters are
vibrant then yeah you can we can work
around that structures is you know it's
it's important absolutely for
screenplays but there are ways to get to
that you know the the characters who are
alive and vibrant and you know
compelling that's really the harder part
I think in some respects great sorry you
just figured a memory of I remember
being a kid and being afraid to have my
grandparents drive me over that oh maybe
that's why I'm afraid of bridges yeah
there was a subconscious coming out so
yeah you brought it out yeah
I forgot all about that do you have any
suggestions to help writers brainstorm
for ideas yes well first of all let's
just imagine that we've got 10 tracks of
our brain ok you know that our brain can
do 10 things at one time one of those
tracks if you're a writer should be
always sensitive to and aware of ideas
they're out there they're out there all
over the place they're in newspaper
articles they're in conversations you
hear with people of the coffee shop
they're on the radio they're on click
your click click thing happens I know
for example I know David Rabinowitz in
Charlie Wachtel who wrote black Klansman
and I interviewed them and I said well
how did you guys come up with it and I
think David said well I was trying to
avoid writing and so I was just doing
the click-click-click thing and I
stumbled on this Facebook article about
this guy Ron Stallworth who was the
first black policeman in Colorado
Springs who then did this thing with the
cubix clan so that's how they discovered
it so one thing is just be conscious of
it the other thing is be intentional you
know like every day you should be
thinking about story ideas now people
are not going to necessarily you know
it's gonna vary from person to person
but there have been times in my life
where I literally said I'm going to come
up with an idea a day every day I'm
gonna come up and it's in and a third
point to that it related his dr. Linus
Pauling who is the only person who went
to Nobel Prizes and he has that saying
the best way to come up with a good idea
is to come up with a lot of ideas and so
that's a third point that you can do is
just generate a lot of ideas keep a file
like I've got a word file stretching
back 20-some odd years with literally
hundreds and hundreds of ideas most of
them awful but you keep working that
muscle and then eventually I think the
chances are that you're going to surface
something now then you have to assess
the ideas and so there's certain
questions you can ask like
is this big enough to be a movie you
know who's the audience for this what's
the hook you know that central conceit
like when I sold k9 you know I remember
going into an executive office and they
said what you guys did was so brilliant
you took the buddy action comedy formula
the police cop and you put in
rin-ten-ten who was like the biggest
star in Hollywood back in the late 20s
and 30s and I learned a very valuable
lesson there which is that you always
when somebody gives you a compliment
even if you didn't mean it you go yeah
that's exactly what I was thinking I
said yeah that's exactly what we're
thinking because I hadn't thought that
at all but you know you that idea I
could walk in at that point in time in
1987 I could have walked into any
producers office or any bar where people
were hanging out what are you working on
I said yeah I got this idea k9 loaner
cop new partner police dog they would
see that so the hook there is the police
dog nobody had done that you know so you
look for like inception the idea of
being able to go on side some of us
Groundhog Day we're living the same that
thing what's that thing that's gonna set
it off from you know something else so
those are some keys you know have one
part of your brain going be intentional
about it you know be generating a lot of
ideas and hoping that you'll come up
with you know some really good ones some
strong ones off that and then assess
them to make sure that you feel like
it's big enough and good enough to be a
movie I have a Joseph Campbell quote
here and it reads if the path before you
is clear you are probably on someone
else's so can this also be applied to
storytelling so if the story you've
begun writing is clear it's probably
already been written yeah that that is
one of my favorite quotes
I love Campbell I'm a huge Joseph
Campbell fan I'm a huge Joseph Campbell
think that was him of course that
wonderful series the power of myth with
Bill Moyers that's unmet flix I think
yes I've watched it yeah it's wonderful
I love his style too oh he he was asked
these one time he said do you pray he
said no I
he read ten hours a day you know I read
thousands and thousands and thousands
own field of study you know I I in my
office when I got my office at DePaul
the first thing I did was I put up on my
white board follow your bliss Joseph
Campbell and it's still there because I
use that when I meet with my students I
want them to see that and I start each
class I'll get to the question I start
each class with that point follow your
bliss you may not hear anything else
from my class that there's a meaning to
you or value to you but this find that
thing that you're passionate about that
energizes you that brings you joy that
you may have talent for and do that
whether it's an avocation or vocation do
that because that's the best chance you
have at living an authentic life of
aligning yourself with something
authentic in yourself so the thing about
the path that's the point you know my
University students given the economic
considerations of where we are nowadays
you know they come in and it's like I
feel I love writing but you know my
parents want me to do this degree and
accounting I say okay you know I
understand it you know in terms of the
economic and security and you're not
guaranteed you know a living in the arts
so maybe what you do is you do that
accounting and you take this as a minor
and you're watching movies and TV and
you're reading scripts and you're
writing and you're doing it as an
application you're doing it because it
brings you joy but at least you're
taking care of paying the bills but at
some point you're gonna probably have to
come up to this point the Campbell said
the path that's laid out for you the
accounting path that's probably not your
path at least creatively and spiritually
you're gonna have to do something that
incorporates this other path
you know Campbell talks about how that's
the should it's getting rid of the
should right and pursuing that which is
authentic to the their bliss so yes and
I do think that that's that's the case
where a lot of writers will look at
things that sell like I would imagine
now
there are probably lots and lots of
scripts that have started to come in
that have images and different font
sizes and stuff like a quiet place
because the movie did quite well that's
over 300 million dollars and so you're
having people emulating a style and a
storytelling way of storytelling that
may not be reflective of their voice
they may be more about imitating someone
else and so that's that question again
but it also relates to the protagonist
the protagonist starts off in a state of
disunity
they are living on someone else's path
the path they need to be living on is
the one they take on their journey so
that that saying of Campbell has
multiple levels of meaning and I think
it's a really profound insight you know
young again inspired Campbell and Young
talked about that the great I can't
remember the next word not honor but the
great task of our existence is to become
who we are that it's already inside us
and it needs to emerge
Campbell talks about the hero's journey
being a journey not of attainment but
retain them so it's already there and it
needs to be recaptured or captured that
path is where the protagonist goes to
uncover that and so again that that Beck
that comment from Campbell has got a lot
of layers of meaning to it
yeah what do you think Joseph Campbell
resonated so much with Carl Jung and not
Freud or Fritz Perl or some of these
other because the same reason I mean
Freud was very reductive you know and
Jung was exactly the opposite which is
why he broke with Freud you know he was
a Mac elated Freud for a while he saw
the universes being that's wide open you
know his father was a minister whose
grandfather was a ministry he thought
about becoming a minister he was very
interested in spiritualism
he had a very open of profound
appreciation for the the wild divergence
and diversity of human experience and so
Campbell was the same way he came back
after spending four or five years in
Europe I think he came back to Columbia
and they said well why don't you become
up get a PhD and you'll have this area
the specific you know specific area of
focus your dissertation will be
something with the : you know da da da
da : that it it uh and he said no I
don't want to do that you know for lack
of a better word he was a generalist he
wanted to explore the diversity of all
these different cultures of all these
different stories and look at them and
find the universality through the
specifics of those stories which is how
he came up with the idea of the hero's
journey so he and young were quite
aligned in that regard
and fact Campbell edited a book on young
and heavily again if you if you read
young you'll see where Campbell got a
lot of its ideas and by the way that is
an excellent interview with bill moyers
oh it's fantastic hours of the Austen
tastic at least watch the first episode
where they talk about Star Wars you know
because he gives he gives a wonderful
I've got on my blog he's got a wonderful
summary of the uros journey like about
of two minutes summary of it and bill
moyers is really the perfect counterpart
to speak with him they they mesh so well
he's a Baptist minister oh and he was
trying to wrap his head around these
rather Eastern notions you know Eastern
you know say like Buddhist notion the
Campbell was a heavily influenced by him
should screenwriters know the ending of
their story before beginning writing one
well again you know no writer is the
same and every story is different I'm
reminded of the Writers Guild strike in
1988 which is the longest strike to date
I broken in 1987 and within a year we
were on strike and that strike lasted I
think 26 weeks half the year and it was
a bummer because he couldn't earn money
but what I did was I would go on these
picketing
the picket line and I would tag the
older writers and because I wanted to
hear about the old Hollywood days you
know the studio system and whatnot and I
remember at the Fox lot there was a
conversation I had with this guy from
New York and I remember his name but he
was very funny very outspoken and he at
one point said to me Scott he said you
got to know four things to know before
you start writing the script
what's the beginning of the story what's
the end of act 1 was the end of act 2
and what's the ending of the story he
said you don't got that you don't got
dick that's what he told and so one of
those is the ending you know again going
back to that bridge analogy if you know
where you're going even if you can't see
maybe you can see in the distance that
light house you know because you know
where you're going and I also another
reason why if you work with the
protagonist and their disunity
oftentimes that indicates that unity
state if you just go 180 degrees from
where they start boom like my favorite
movie is the apartment with Jack Lemmon
and at the beginning of the movie he
finds himself in a really weird
situation he gave his key to his
apartment he's a bachelor to an
upper-level management guy who just
asked him for a favor one night to carry
out a tryst as it turns out an
extramarital affair so at the beginning
of the story we see CC Baxter Jack
Lemmon where there are these four upper
level management guys who are using his
apartment almost nightly and so he's
living in a state of disunity and that
he's not even able to live in his
apartment moreover he's basically a
decent guy but the reason he's doing
that is because these guys all say the
same thing like after every night hey
buddy boy we got a review
coming up gonna give you good marks
hopefully get that promotion cuz he
works in this like C of accounting
people with you no no they weren't even
cubicles it's like he's just a little
desk and he's bought into the corporate
mentality he wants to go up the
corporate ladder not necessarily because
he's greedy he just wants to get into a
better wait station in life but that's
his state of disunity and he's also
enamored of Fran cupola who's Shirley
MacLaine the elevator operator but he
can't screw up the courage to ask her
out as it turns out she's having an
affair with his boss mr. Sheldrake fred
macmurray
and so that crushes him when he finds
out worse Sheldrake asks for the key
which means that he's now having an
affair with the woman that Baxter loves
in Baxter's house apartment and in his
bed right so just a horrible situation
well if you look at where he is he's
enamored of the corporate thing and yet
he's in love with this woman and we know
he's basically a decent guy
you can almost see where eventually he's
gonna have to reject the corporate thing
which is what he does but there are
things he needs to go through along the
way he needs to bond with Fran Kubik she
has an attempted suicide at his place
and so they're together for two or three
days so they have a chance to connect
with each other he's got an extra
neighbor dr. Dreyfuss who's the mentor
figure everybody in the apartment
building thinks that Jack the Baxter is
having all these parties all the time
you know if the doctor says when you die
I want to donate your body to the
University we want to see that how you
did that you know but so dr. Dreyfuss
gets to him and says what do you need he
says you need to be a mensch you know
what that is Baxter a human being and
he's given that advice so at the end of
the day when Sheldrick he's now at this
point by the end of the movie Baxter is
now in the office next to Sheldrick on
the 26th floor so he has completely
achieved like
the ultimate in corporate life he's
right there right next to the boss
well the boss asks for his key again
because he had to throw it out because
his a Farragut he's now separated from
his wife and this whole thing and Baxter
doesn't give it to him
he gives him the key to the executive
washroom instead and Sheldrake is like
what are you doing is this a that your
old pal that won't work with me he says
you know what I become a mensch a human
being so he takes those words so you can
see by the fact that he starts off in
the state of disunity where he's bought
into the corporate mentality that if
he's gonna achieve unity he's gonna
probably reject that so I do think that
that knowing the end of the story is
critical but it's often time indicated
right there just by virtue of what you
learn about your protagonist at the
beginning which is interesting because
the Graduate is kind of a twist on that
it's where he doesn't want to be part of
the corporate world and he's still
having an affair but it's it's almost
out of desperation because it doesn't
know what to do with this life and he's
got all this pressure and you know
plastics that's what you know it's just
interesting because that's kind of a yes
absolutely
he's completely lost and floundering he
doesn't buy into the Ben Benjamin he
doesn't buy into the plastic existence
of his parents and their friends and
that whole thing in that generation and
he turns to this affair with mrs.
Robinson you know just because it's
something to do and it's not really that
he becomes at all even approximating
what is his authentic nature until he
meets Elaine mrs. Robinson's daughter
and that's when he finally gets on board
but even that's a little bit fraudulent
because it's like he's so desperately
yearning for some meaning in his life he
projects that onto her which is why at
the end when the director said did not
say cut in the bus he just let that keep
rolling and you see them sort of they're
excited at first and then
they're just kind of sitting there and
they don't know what they've done really
you know remember 500 days of summer
where they say at the beginning Tom um
you know Hannah I figured Tom had a bad
notary but you know a flawed notion of
what romance was due to his his his bad
interpretation of the ending of of the
Graduate you know cuz he thinks they
fall in love how beautiful and really
it's not that way at all it's like he
just did this out of desperation and
wanting to rebel and find some meaning I
think he really necessarily loved her
and she she wanted to rebell too you
know so that's a bad and she runs off
with him so yeah that's another case of
the character it's totally he starts off
in a state of disunity and sort of moves
toward unity but not really have a
William Goldman quote here and one of
his quotes reads screenplays are
structure and that's all they are so do
you agree with this quote and why do you
think so many screenwriters argue about
structure well first of all I do I mean
it's hard to not agree with William
Goldman who was arguably the Dean of
contemporary American screenwriters I
mean an amazing legacy and I never met
him but I know people who have and just
said that he was just the greatest guy
and so the idea that screenplays are
structure there's a very real way in
which that's true I think ultimately a
screenplay as a pre movie it's you know
it's it's a template and a guide to make
a movie and so there is a structural
component just that like that where it
gets budgeted and you know they do
everything that they have to do in terms
of the pre-production of production from
a writing standpoint it's also true
because beginning middle and end and
subplots and all that stuff to why
people argue about it I think that a lot
of it is people want or are inclined to
think about screenplays at a surface
level like page counts and act breaks
and that sort of thing stylistic things
like you can't have any unfilmable Zoar
facts or voice-over narration is weak
writing because that puts the
conversation in a realm where it's
pretty easy and in reality to write a
great script it's none of that
it's all about immersing yourself in the
lives of your characters and seeing what
emerges from that process and that's not
easy and there is no golden parachute
secret way of doing that characters are
slippery and many of them are hard to
know and figuring out the relationships
and what they need and what they want
and they're conscious goal and I'm
conscious goal and examining their
personal history which is everything
that's happened to them to find out
their backstory elements which are the
key elements that come forward into the
story that's hard work and that requires
trust and faith that the characters
exist and that's that's a conversation
that people I think are afraid of and so
they'll argue about story structure and
I've seen this flame wars I wrote a blog
a series of blog articles on these
so-called screenwriting rules they want
to talk about these rules there are no
rules if there were rules there would be
rule books there are conventions there
are expectations
there are even paradigms but not rules
and so people want to reduce it to rules
they want to reduce it to formula they
want to reduce it to specific paradigms
to structure as plot when structure is
not just plot there's the external world
of action and dialogue which I call the
plot line that's the realm of the
physical journey that's only half the
story there's the internal world so
where there's dialogue there's subtext
and where there's action there's
intention one of the characters
intentions behind there
actions and where there's the plot line
there's a theme line so the plot line
answers a question what is the story
about the theme line answers the
question what does the story mean and
that's the psychological journey
compared to the physical journey and so
that conversation that we are constantly
floating around that's up there in that
top round the plot line structure as
plot you need to get down in that other
part that's where the conversation needs
to be having that we need to be having
that conversation moreover as I said up
front I think that's where you start the
conversation that's your dialogue with
the story is with the characters that I
don't care what paradigm they use if
they've started with the characters and
immerse themselves in the lives of those
characters more often than that they're
gonna come up with the story structure
out of that and those characters are
gonna be alive and vibrant so the the
again the answer I think is that people
are not comfortable with that sort of
engagement with characters on an
existential level where you believe they
exist and now I'm asking you to do to
get inside their heads or talk to them
or engage them in conversation that's I
think for many people something that
they feel uncomfortable with if they can
say oh yeah they need to have the the
break into Act 2 on page 25 it can't be
B to page 23 they can't be page 29 every
25 they're more comfortable with that
because it's it makes it more it makes
it simpler you know so are there no
great writers just great rewriters I'm
not sure that's a quote of yours I think
I found no it's it's there you know
writing is rewriting yeah they've that's
probably more true of screenwriting than
maybe any other narrative form just
because there are so many layers to get
a movie made there's you as the writer
and so you get feedback from your writer
friends you know the writers group if
you're represented you get feedback from
your managers and sometimes your agents
depending upon
you know what your relationship is with
your agents then if you're working with
a producer you get feedback from the
producer and if you've got it set up at
a studio or a production company or
financier you get feedback from them
then if the thing gets greenlit now you
got actors and directors attached well
now you're gonna have feedback from the
director you're gonna have feedback from
each of the individual actors sometimes
they have their own writers and then you
have to then synthesize what the what
the other writers have done to their
characters and so for example I know
Erik Heiser er quite well and he wrote a
rifle which is absolutely one of the you
know all-time fantastic scripts and I
asked him I said how many drafts did you
do and he said 100 now most of those are
like changing a line you know but he
would just he would codify each one just
so he knew you know or dropping a scene
or adding two scenes or whatever so I
think probably out of that maybe 10 or
15 drafts you know but yeah you you know
I tell my students University students
when they gone through all this work of
developing a story and then they sit
down to write you know a draft of and I
say okay you just have to understand
it's not gonna be perfect you're gonna
have to rewrite it and they go oh really
you know they're not used to that talk
to them two three years later they
completely understand you know but yeah
rewriting writing is rewriting them
dialogue is not conversation its
conversation with the purpose it's it's
people conversing but every line needs
to move the story forward in some
respect whether it's moving the plot
forward through some sort of revelation
that a character makes or moves these
characters forward in their own
relationship because they have an
argument and that conflict causes one of
them both of them or more of them to
shift in terms of their thought
processes and feelings or it provides
some exposition some information some
data which is a key to help them get a
clue to move the thing forward
but yeah dialogue is conversation but
it's conversation with a purpose you
need to be really mindful of that
so that's tricky because it's got to be
entertaining too
you know and in an ideal world it's more
often than not it's subtextual so that
what's being communicated is really more
about what's underneath the words than
the words themselves it's also dialogue
is also the words that aren't spoken
sometimes the best dialogue is what's
not said so I get the message like is
dialogue conversation and there's a the
subtext there is don't make it just like
how people talk in real life like
because we just go
we just blabber on and on and on we
don't have that amount of time in a
screenplay you need to be precise and
efficient but yes it is conversational B
it should sound conversational like how
characters would talk in the real world
so I get it but yeah it's conversation
with a purpose that would be my take on
that
are there any films that are really a
great study in subtext I would say I
would read anything by Tony Gilroy like
Michael Clayton that script
he doesn't he's just he's just an
amazing writer
and Michael Clayton is a really just
it's a syrup that anybody should just
read because he not only has subtext
going on but the text is so entertaining
and there's layers to it so that
sometimes he's saying like what's
absolutely on the characters mind so the
text is like right there and so in the
words the meaning of the words are right
up top but then there's other layers
underneath too so he's really brilliant
and Michael Clayton is a script I
absolutely recommend